even sexual harassment and assault can
be made into partisan issues president
Trump finally sounds off on judge Roy
more plus Al Franken and we go to the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so yesterday I said that we
were in the midst of a flaming garbage
fire in American politics how wrong I
was we were only on the edge of the
flaming garbage pile yesterday but today
we are definitely in the center of the
flaming garbage heap after all the
fallout from Al Franken after the fact
that it now appears that every Democrat
will end up standing with Al Franken and
it appears that every Republican or a
lot of Republicans wound up standing
with Roy Moore
it appears that no one really cares
about bad conduct which is very
upsetting to me personally cuz I don't
like that but we will talk about all of
these things in just one second first I
want to say thank you to our friends
over at quip so if you are if you're
concerned about not just your oral
hygiene but your actual health then you
should be concerned about how you brush
your teeth because there actually is
connection between how you brush your
teeth and things like heart health
according to studies that's why you need
to use clip that's why I use clip so
quip there's a new company refreshing
the way people brush their teeth it's an
electric toothbrush that packs premium
vibration and timer features into an
ultra slim design half the cost of
bulkier brushes it's like Apple designed
two toothbrushes very slim it's very
sleek battery-powered and it has a timer
on it as well so you know when you're
done brushing your top teeth and I can
move on to your bottom teeth
it starts at just $25 and if you go to
get clipped comm slash up hero you get
your first refill pack free so they send
you you can put it on a schedule to get
refill packs for the for the tip of the
brush which ensures that you're not
using an old brush head and you can
subscribe and get a recommended
three-month plan for just $5 including
free shipping so go to get quick comm
slash up hero and you get all of that
plus the first refill pack free with
equip electric toothbrush first refill
pack free get quick calm / up here o GE
t qu IP comm / up here oh it's the
toothbrush that I use and it's also
great when bringing on the road as
opposed to other electric toothbrushes
that have a huge you know kind of
recharging mechanism you don't have that
with clips so get clip comm / up hero
that also lets them know that we say
okay so we there's a bunch of fallout
from Al Franken and Roy Moore and I want
to begin with a piece in today's
Washington Post so yesterday they're a
bunch of Democrats you sort of pretended
that they
about Al Franken so the allegation
against Al Franken again is that he
groped a woman while she was sleeping
this this woman her name is Leanne
tweetIn yeah Leanne Tweed
she's a talk show host out here in Los
Angeles and she alleges that Al Franken
groped her while she was sleeping and
then during a rehearsal I had written a
kiss into a scene when he was a comedian
and said he rammed his tongue down her
throat which is just disgusting and so
all of this had created an enormous
amount of an enormous amount of
controversy in fact we can start with
Leon Sweden talking about Frank and here
is what Leon Sweden had to say about its
clip 9 the world that you're making for
your children for your two-year-old and
for your four-year-old do you realize
that you are making it better for them I
don't know the genders of your children
but it actually doesn't even matter have
a boy and a girl
okay well but it's but both of them need
to be impacted by this right not just
the girl you know you always sorry
nothing to be sorry about
huh didn't thinking I was gonna do that
but you know you do you you want to
leave you know you try to set examples
for your children right you want to
leave the world a better place okay and
so the allegations against Franken are
obviously serious enough that yesterday
bunch of people said well we'll start to
send an ethics committee investigation
and Franken himself calls for a Senate
Ethics investigation there's only one
problem with this it's total nonsense
between 2006 and 2007 teen or between
rather 2007 and 2016 there were six
hundred and thirteen different Senate
ethics investigation requests how many
punishments were handed down how many
sanctions were handed down zero giant
zero so when Democrats say yeah we're
treating Al Franken with the gravest
seriousness no you're not Plus what
would you have an ethics investigation
about there's a picture of him trying to
grab her boobs while she's sleeping what
exactly is the is the investigation
going to be senator franken did you try
to grab that woman's boobs senator
franken there's a picture of it but it
was joke ethics committee well there's a
picture of it him I take the fifth like
well what is the investigation going to
be about here exactly and now we know
okay the fact is that the left is
willing to throw people under the bus
when they're no longer useful to them
but they want to stick with them when
they are useful right when it's Bill
Clinton now they can throw Bill Clinton
under the bus they were in a bunch of
articles this week about how Bill
Clinton should resign in 1998
thanks for getting around to it 19 years
late getting and now they're a bunch of
articles about how Al Franken should
stick around so his woman in Kate
Harding who's the co-editor of nasty
women feminism resistance and Revolution
in Trump's America so she's a feminist
right she she hosts a podcast called
feminists II which sounds like death on
the ears and here is what and and she
wrote a piece for The Washington Post
today called I am a feminist I study
rape culture and I don't want Al Franken
to resign yeah I'm freaking shocked she
says as a feminist and the author of a
book on rape culture I could reasonably
be expected to lead the calls for Al
Franken's a step tone font of the step
down following allegations that he
forced his tongue down a woman's throat
accompanied by a photo of him grinning
as he moves in to grope her breasts
while she sleeps
it's disgusting he treated a sleeping
woman as a comedy prop no more human
than the contents of carrot tops trunk
and I firmly believe he should suffer
social and professional consequences for
it but I don't believe resigning from
his position is the only possible
consequence or the one that's best for
American women cynics on both the right
and left will presume I am passing by
this particular steam trance
17 smorgasbord the feminist outraged
because Franken is a Democrat and so am
i I was even as proud constituent for
two years in the most superficial sense
this is true and that's not just the
most perfect that's like the only sense
there is no deeper sense that you think
Franken is gonna vote the way you arm to
vote and so you're fine with this so
this is just an this is just a variation
on the old Time magazine columnist Neda
brulees comment about Bill Clinton that
she'd be willing to offer him oral sex
so long as you kept abortion legal and
we're seeing this on both sides of the
aisle now and it's just gross and I
think it's something we need to come to
grips with our own gross misses humans
before we can actually fix it if people
talk about raising awareness so I'm not
into raising awareness when it's
counterproductive but I think it is
about raising awareness when it comes to
examining your own political motives
because I think that we all have
political motives and that leads us into
certain cul-de-sacs of partisan
aggression that I think are negative
she says it's meaningless to say it's
because I'm a Democrat without asking
why I am a Democrat if you understand
what it means to be a Democrat today
that is why it makes sense to vote blue
over red in this highly polarized
political environment you can understand
why it might not make the most sense to
demand Franklin's resignation effective
immediately I'm a Democrat because I'm a
feminist who lives under a two-party
system I am NOT a true believer in the
party nor in any politician I'm a
realist who recognizes we get two viable
choices so this is the exact argument
the exact argument that is now being
used to back Roy Moore she says isn't
that hypocritical I hear you asking
because Republicans won't do the right
thing we shouldn't either
but if the short-term right thing leads
to long-term political catastrophe for
American women I think we need to
reconsider our definition of the right
thing okay so this is the exact opposite
of the argument I mean it's it's the
same argument actually that's being made
it's just the photo negative of the
argument that's being made by a lot of
people who are backing Roy Moore saying
listen if Doug Jones gets in the Senate
he's gonna vote for abortion I hate
abortion so if I have to choose I'll
choose to vote for Roy Moore that's the
say it's the photo- argument and the
problem is that both sides make this
argument we will get people who are
alleged sexual molesters and sexual
assaulters in the Senate chock-a-block
they will be there all the time and then
none of this is going to change change
comes about when we realize that the
ends don't always justify the means
realize that yes I would not vote for
Doug Jones yes I would you know I would
not vote for Al Franken but that doesn't
mean that just because somebody is bad I
have to vote for their opponent or I
can't find a third
Lucian I can't find some sort of right
in solution so all of this is very
upsetting and disappointing and it makes
us feel like we have nothing in common
because we don't write we don't have
anything in common if we're to the point
where we believe that sexual molestation
or sexual assault allegations can be put
by the wayside because it's more
important to defeat the other side then
we can't live in a republic with each
other we just can't I mean the the the
the end of the republic has basically
come now with all of this happening you
can see that the politicians are using
this particular mentality is a way to
maintain power this is happening on both
sides so you know for example Roy Moore
has been hit with all of these terrible
allegations he's coming back now
and he's saying the Mitch McConnell
should step down so the more partisan
Roy Moore gets the more he knows he's
protected right to harbor opposition he
takes the more firing a position if he
takes the more he knows that there are
people who are gonna rally to his side
so quote/unquote opposed the other side
so here is Roy Moore attacking Mitch
McConnell saying McConnell should be the
one who steps down not me right not me
I'm gonna stand here wearing my cross
and American flag pin amidst allegations
that I have not rebutted in any serious
way Mitch McConnell is the one who
should step down listen I'm not a fan of
Mitch McConnell but this has nothing to
do with McConnell but again the more
partisan you can make the argument the
more you know that people will rally to
your side so here's my here is Roy Moore
saying this all I want to tell you who
needs to step down
that's Mitch McConnell
there's been comments about me taking a
stand yes I have taken a stand in the
past I'll take a stand in the future and
I'll quit standing when they lay me in
that box and put me in the ground well
that's weird
and then Bob Menendez does the same
thing from the other side so Bob
Menendez was not acquitted but there was
a home jitters a mistrial in his trial
yesterday and so he comes out and he
turns it into a partisan issue knowing
that his own side will rally around him
as they were going to Democrats would
not even answer the question whether if
Menendez was convicted they would expel
him from the Senate they might keep him
there right now Menendez is coming out
and making this partisan and making it
even more partisan so the more part we
now live in a dynamic where the more
partisan you can make any issue any
personal issue the better chance you
have of surviving it right Bill Clinton
was able to turn sexual molestation
allegations sexual misconduct
allegations he was able to turn those
allegations in his own favor by
suggesting that it was a vast right-wing
conspiracy you're seeing more to the
same thing it's best left wing and
establishment conspiracy you're saying
Bob Menendez do the same thing on
corruption it's a vast right-wing and
racist conspiracy here's Mendez doing
that yesterday to those who left me who
abandoned me in my darkest moment I
forgive you to those who embraced me in
my darkest moment I love you to those in
New Jerseyans who gave me the benefit of
the doubt I thank to those who were
digging my political grave so that they
could jump into my seat I know who you
are and I won't forget you she's making
him partisan right everyone who backed
him he'll remember and he will love you
and if I mean this is this mafioso type
language right and if you if you didn't
back him I'll remember you and I will
never forget you your name will be
emblazoned on my memory forever again if
you can use partisanship to distract
from your own misconduct then we're just
gonna get the worst of the worst in in
every situation okay so finally here's
what happens done the the pole in
Alabama right now with Roy Moore show
the latest poll from Fox News shows that
Roy Moore is down eight I don't believe
that poll I think that a lot of people
are lying to the pollsters and and I
think that the race is actually much
closer than that the reason I believe
that is because if you look at the
Alabama results for the last
election cycles what you see is that no
Republican candidate in Alabama since
2002 has lost has law has one less than
60% of the so Republicans outnumber
Democrats in the state like two to one
so the idea that he's losing by eight
points would be truly shocking but you
know that with that said he is you know
apparently in a tight race he's losing
the race and he won't step down and as
I've said before the only person who
could really step in and put an end to
Roy Moore's run here would be President
Trump so we'll get to president Trump's
reaction to all of these things finally
he's speaking out but not in the way
that I would like we'll get to all of
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors /
Theo's concealed carry Association so if
you are going on or can you say with
100% confidence that your family and
your home are safe what if you're forced
to pull the trigger and you know what
happens next
do you know what to say when the police
arrive you'll find the answers in the
u.s. CCA's complete concealed carry and
family defense guide and you can get
yours completely free but you have to
act now it's 164 page guide and a free
audiobook and you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you
the safest and most dangerous places to
sit in a restaurant how to responsibly
own and store a gun even if you have
little kids and more but they're only
offering this to my listeners for a few
more days so if you want your free copy
you have to hurry go over to defend my
family now calm let's defend my family
now calm and get your free copy of this
hundred and sixty four page guide that
will make your life a lot safer because
you'll know a lot more needed yesterday
defend my family now calm again that's
defending my family now calm go over and
check it out that address also lets them
know that we sent you ok so president
Trump is finally sounding off about
about Roy Moore but he's not actually
speaking so he sends out Sarah Huckabee
Sanders to talk about it so what is his
position
that's a trump who has a position on
everything right he had a position on
Jamel Hill at ESPN he said she should be
fired
he said the Colin Kaepernick is a son of
a who should be fired right even
though he wasn't really in the NFL of
time yeah and you know I may agree with
his assessments on people who kneel for
the anthem and I may agree that Jamel
Hill not that she should be fired I
don't think she should have been fired
but that she was wrong in her assessment
of politics but he's been completely
silent on Roy Moore for over a week even
though he endorsed Roy Moore at for one
more one the primary so finally Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is trotted out to
answer questions about about Roy Moore
and what this does demonstrate by the
way is that Sean Hannity in the White
House are very much in court
because as you recall Sean Hannity the
night before last came out and said that
he wants let the people of Alabama
decide the White House is giving exactly
the same message so that is a shift
apparently there were reports that Sean
had been getting calls from Bannon and
from the White House saying back off Roy
Moore a little bit so the White House is
is also backing off of Roy Moore here's
Sarah Huckabee Sanders saying that Trump
thinks the people of Alabama ought to
decide which is a truism again I said
this yesterday you know when people say
things like let the people decide what
they're really saying is that they are
not going to take a position right
that's really what they're saying and
that's stupid okay Trump is taking a
position on everything his is I mean
literally everything all the things
Trump has taken a position on but here
he chooses to go strategically silent
the reason that that's bad is not just
because I think it's immoral even though
I do think it's immoral the reason that
I think it's bad is because Donald Trump
is one of the very few people in America
who could actually make a difference in
this Senate race and actually make sure
that Republicans keep the seat without
that seat being Roy Moore's here is
here's Sarah Huckabee Sanders though
basically kicking the can down the road
the President believes that these
allegations are very troubling and
should be taken seriously and he thinks
that the people of Alabama should make
the decision on who their next senator
should be look the president said in his
statement earlier this week that if the
allegations are true then that Roy Moore
should step aside he still firmly
believes that okay so you know that
doesn't mean anything right we now know
what we know okay what nothing further
is really gonna come out here the idea
that if true he should step aside but
let the people of Alabama decide again
the people of Alabama will decide right
but he can have an impact on this race
if you were to come out and say Roy
Moore get out people of Alabama
you know don't lose the Senate race
because of Roy Moore that would actually
have an impact in this race but that's
not what's happening here then you know
and then Trump tweets but but so Trump
doesn't say anything about more right
but he does have some things to say
about Al Franken so the allegations come
out about Franken he's been completely
silent on Twitter right he's been over
in Asia this was the excuse for him not
commenting on more he comes back and now
he's on he's on Twitter late at night
and so Trump starts tweeting about Al
Franken say tweets the l frank enstein
picture and it's it Frankenstein right
but he spells Frankenstein ie instead of
E I again spellcheck says the Al
Frankenstein picture is really bad
speaks a thousand words where do his
hands go in pictures two three four five
and six while she sleeps random then he
continues along these lines and he says
and to think that just last week he was
lecturing anyone who would listen about
sexual harassment and respect for women
Lesley Stahl tape the Lesley Stahl tape
is a reference to him making jokes about
about sexually abusing Lesley Stahl
while she's asleep or something now so
you know Trump is perfectly willing to
sound off about Franken now a lot of
people on the right love this about
Trump that he's not shy about sounding
off about political opposition and when
it comes to the partisan battles this is
the thing that they really enjoy about
Trump is that Trump is always happy to
throw a punch in the other direction
this is also a really stupid strategy
okay the reason this is stupid strategy
is we are now going to get a full week
of talk about all of the sexual
harassment and abuse allegations against
Donald Trump okay there were something
like 15 or 16 women who made sexual
assault or harassment allegations
against Trump at the end of the last
election cycle we had not yet had the
Harvey Weinstein blow-up so now we're
gonna get to redo all of that which is
really really exciting and it's one of
the reasons by the way I think that
Trump has not actually come out and
openly condemn more because the problem
is that once you condemn more once you
get involved in these issues now it
comes back around to you right just as
Trump says you know Al Franken was
talking about sexual harassment and
negative way but then he was sexually
harassing people it's very hard for
Trump to be the leader the tip of the
spear on sexual harassment and abuse and
Huckabee Sanders was specifically asked
by a reporter over at Fox News about
this right here's Huckabee Sanders being
asked to comment on the allegations
against Trump we should find one set of
allegations very troubling and on the
other we shouldn't pay attention to them
at all or we should totally disbelieve
them well I think the president has
certainly a lot more insight into what
he personally did or didn't do and he
spoke out about that directly during the
campaign and I don't have anything
further to add beyond that okay so
basically we're gonna keep silent on
this because we don't want the blowback
to come back around this is the problem
with having our standards that we have
our own double standard okay we have our
own double standard and then our
politicians pay the price for the double
standard on the one hand we say that if
they're on our side we don't care and on
the other side on the other hand we say
if they're not on our side we do care
that double standard has ramifications
for politicians because it means that
Trump is gonna want to condemn Al
Franken but if he condemns Al Franken
it's gonna come back around to trump and
then the right is gonna have to suggest
it was that the allegations about Trump
are not credible but the allegations
against
Franken are super credible which I don't
buy by the way I think the allegations
against Trump we're credible during the
primaries I think they were or during
the general election I again don't say
that you shouldn't have voted for Trump
to stop Hillary but I do think that yeah
I didn't yeah you know I didn't vote at
the top of the ticket because I take
these things very very seriously so you
know the idea that that we can have as a
people this double standard in our mind
that has to change so either we're gonna
say as a public we're gonna say as a
public one of two things we care about
these allegations enough to get rid of
people doesn't matter their political
affiliation or we don't care enough to
get rid of people doesn't matter that
our political affiliation we're gonna
have to make that decision otherwise we
just have this hypocritical standard now
I do want to talk a little bit about the
generalized societal problem that's
that's coming up with some of these
sexual harassment allegations and that
is as I've said now for a couple of
weeks really six weeks since the Harvey
Weinstein's stuff broke we as a society
do not have a consistent standard that
we are applying with regard to what sort
of allegations to take seriously and
what sort of allegations not to take
seriously so well the reason that I say
this is because we are treating sexual
harassment allegations where a guy has
said something nasty and untoward to a
woman the same as we are treating rape
allegations and that seems to me not
correct I think that you can condemn
both but I don't think they are worthy
of equal levels of condemnation now for
example there is the the actress Ellen
Page and Ellen Page
had this whole thing about my director
she worked with or a fellow actor she
worked for the count member who she's
talking about who had said some you know
it was Ratner I was about Ratner I guess
who's had a lot of sexual allegations
made against him and she says that Brett
Ratner at one point made some sort of
nasty lesbian reference to her on the
set and this is bad it is bad okay and
he deserves to be condemned before that
obviously and then she says in that same
allegation in the same Facebook post she
says that at one point she was sexually
assaulted by a grip okay these are not
the same kind of thing right they're
both bad but they're not quite the same
kind of bad right rape and sexual
assault are not the same thing as sexual
harassment and conflating the two
actually ends up making light of sexual
assault because it allows people to
slough it off it allows people to
basically say okay you know that's the
same as saying something nasty look
sexually harassing a woman and sexually
assaulting a woman are not quite the
same thing they're both bad but there
are different levels of bad
right it's bad - it's bad to hit a child
it's worse to kill a child right it's
bad - it's bad to yell at somebody it's
much worse to hit somebody so I think
that we need to be careful about the
standards that we apply and also the
credibility of particular of particular
standards the reason that I've been so
harsh on Roy Moore is because I find the
allegations particularly credible
because they're supporting details
it's the reason I found one Nina
Broderick to be credible I think they're
supporting details she was in the place
she said she was at the time she said
she was there were contemporaneous
people that she had told at the time but
I think that one of the things that that
is going to happen now is the the
hysteria is is so loud and so much that
there's the possibility that we're gonna
jump to conclusions we shouldn't jump to
conclusions I've called for a certain
level of credibility but I think that we
should determine for ourselves what
exactly that level of credibility is in
other words I'm calm I'm calling for a
standard because otherwise sexual
harassment sexual abuse these are just
gonna become clubs that you can wield
against the other side rather than a
real attempt to cleanse the Society of a
grave evil is so so just wanted I think
that's that's worth worth commenting
upon other comment that I don't wanna
make so yesterday I tweeted something
and all these feminists went nuts
because they didn't understand what I
was saying I tweeted that it seems like
the only solution here is robot
politicians I was not specifically
speaking about sexual harassment I'm
saying all of our politicians suck and a
lot of politicians are willing to cover
for people who suck okay Kirsten
Gillibrand is one of them she came out
yesterday and she said the bill clinton
should have resigned in 1998 she was
literally campaigning with him six
months ago so no okay it's all of our
politicians are garbage you may get less
sexual harassment if women they're more
women in Congress I think you probably
would but that doesn't mean that the
legislation would be any better or that
they wouldn't cover for bad behavior
okay that's just the reality of the
situation we as society have abandoned a
particular moral standard and that moral
stand that comes with consequences okay
none of this arises in a vacuum sexual
harassment sexual abuse these have
always happened but we also used to have
certain standards of behavior that we
demanded from our politicians and that
we demanded from people more generally
now we live in a society where those
standards don't exist unless we almost
randomly decide that they exist again so
that's not a consistent standard or or
don't have a standard at all but don't
don't this were this kind of pick and
choose routine is a very dangerous for
the heart of our politics double
standards don't work okay
before I go any further and I want to
get to some things I like and things I
hate and I really want to spend some
time with the mailbag today first I want
to say thank you for sponsor is over at
upside coms that business trip that
you're about to book do it at upside
comm and you'll get two fantastic gifts
first you get a free pair of Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones so you can
have some peace and quiet on your
business trip and second you get a
better business travel experience we use
up side com2 book my business trips all
the time only upside has customer
service specialists who look out for you
at every step of the way handling any
problem right their team is available
24/7 so if there's screw-up with your
flight or if your hotel or if your
rental car you call them up and there's
someone on the other end of the phone
they're available on-demand by chat by
phone by email whenever you need them
they monitor your business trip around
the clock they proactively keep you
posted on everything from the weather in
the city where you're going to changing
your flight home so you can adjust your
meeting schedule it's really terrific
service it's one of the things that's
been missing in sort of the travel arena
is that once you've booked your ticket
you're totally screwed if something goes
wrong not the case over at upside con so
here is how you can get your free pair
of Bose Soundlink wireless headphones
book your first business trip at upside
calm and use my code Ben and the Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones are yours
for free that is code been at upside
calm to claim my gift again that's Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones just for
trying Upside one more way that up side
is looking out for you helping reduce
the stress of business travel upside
calm because you deserve a better
business trip a minimum purchases
required see the site for complete
details remember up site calm and use
promo code been at checkout and you will
get those headphones plus that lets them
know that we set you which is which is
great ok so now let's just go to some
some things i like and some things that
I hate cuz I really I always kind of
give short shrift to the mailbag and I
don't want to do that this week so
things I like and things that I hate so
we'll start with things I like yes on
the plane I had some very long flights
and I got to watch a couple of movies
one was Wind River the other one that I
saw was the lost city of Z the marketing
campaign for this movie was really quite
terrible one of the reasons the
marketing campaign was terrible is if
you looked at some of the original
posters it was not clear this was a
period piece this is a better poster for
the lost city of Z makes clear that this
is a period piece about exploration it
is also true that the title of the film
is really bad it shouldn't be called the
lost city of Z they should have called
it the Explorer or something you know
something that that actually the the
interest of the film
is not really in the search for velocity
of Z it's really in the biography of the
of the central character of the film
when the performances in this film are
actually quite good
I'm not a big Charlie Hunnam fan I find
him a nerd but Robert Pattinson gives a
terrific performance I didn't know
Robert Pattinson could act as Malthus
was pointing out to me before the show
both Robert Pattinson and Kristen and
Kristen Stewart can act but as Donald
Trump said she treated him like a dog
and she'll do it again just watch so
Robert Pattinson is very very good in
this movie uh then the movie is about an
explorer named Fossett and he is
searching for this city in the Amazon he
thinks that there is this lost city in
the Amazon this sort of city of gold and
he goes searching for it and he sort of
leaves his wife and children behind his
wife's play by sea on a Miller who's
quite good in the film and all the
performances actually across the board
except for hums are pretty good so here
is a here's a little bit of the preview
to dream to seek the unknown to look for
what is beautiful is its own reward a
man's reach should exceed his grasp or
what's a heaven
you are their Explorer
even your hand
I wish to find a lost city
what do you seek is far greater
and you ever imagined okay so the the
preview is you can see it's beautifully
directed it's really well acted it's
really Oscar bait and it's been largely
ignored it didn't do any sort of
business at the theater so far as I can
tell even though it's got a bunch of
big-name actors and a really big budget
and it's beautifully shot there's a
whole world war one sequence that's
really well done so it's it's it's well
worth watching it is not an uplifting
film it sort of tries to be and it sort
of tries to be politically correct at
the same time there are few kind of
politically correct tropes in there but
it's well we're for watching okay so I
have more things that I like and some
things that I hate in the mailbag but
for that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire comm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire comm that means that you get
the rest of my show on video live it
means they get to be part of the mailbag
so if you subscribe right this minute
you can be part of the mailbag which
we'll be doing in about five minutes
and you can ask me questions and I have
all your life's questions answered you
also get the rest of Andrew Clavin show
live there are some Michael Moses show
live we're gonna start doing a new show
on Fridays that that's that should be
pretty great where we just sit around
discuss culture me and Clavin anoles and
Jeremy boring the the god-king of daily
wire so that should be a lot of fun plus
you are going to be able to get
discounts at the shapiro store when that
does come it will come I've been
promising it it's like the wall it's
gonna happen I promise
except unlike the wall it may actually
happen but if you wait at the annual
subscription for $99 a year you will
also get this the very finest in all
beverage vessels the leftist here is hot
or cold mug I will call it a mug just to
spite steven crowder it is spectacular
it is grand and glorious so you get that
as well if you just want to listen later
go over to YouTube subscribe make sure
that you go to iTunes and SoundCloud
subscribe there and and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so a couple of other things
that I like so I'm trying to do a little
more things I like this week because the
news has been just such a dumpster it's
just been terrible and speaking of bad
news it's now breaking that it looks
like the tax the tax reform bill is at
least on the rope Senator Ron Johnson
has said he's not gonna vote for it as
it currently stands Lisa Murkowski
saying she's not gonna vote for as it
currently stands so they're basically
one one vote away from the thing
collapsing so but but let's do some good
news okay so this I thought was just
super cute so this came from ABC News
there's a little five-year-old kid who's
coming back from kindergarten on the
school bus and his three-year-old sister
is waiting for him and this is just
adorable
[Music]
if you can't see it he's just giving her
a big hug and carrying around and then
they're walking home Nia it's super cute
so as a parent of two this is the best
thing the worst thing in the world as a
parent is when your kids are beating the
crap out of each other it's really it's
really hard to watch but when my when my
daughter my who's older she's three and
a half when she treats my son really
well and when he when she gets half of
the more he loves her
I mean he's obsessed with her like she
she gets up in the morning he gets up
earlier than she does and then her name
is Leah he goes yeah yeah and then he
runs into her room because he loves her
so much and then you know she'll give
him a big hug it's the cutest thing in
the world so this kind of stuff is
really fantastic apparently they used to
fight a lot and now that he went to
school she realizes what she's missing
and she's happy when her brother comes
home so that's it that's just cute stuff
okay other things that are that I like
so Orrin Hatch senator from Utah finally
lost with sherrod Brown shirt brown his
senator from Ohio and just a terrible
terrible senator and he was ripping on
the tax reform bill suggesting that it
hurts the middle class which is
absolutely untrue the vast vast vast
vast vast majority of Americans in
particular in the middle class got a tax
cut from this bill and Orrin Hatch
basically laid the wood to sherrod Brown
for suggesting otherwise I come from the
poor people and I've been here working
my whole second career for people who
don't have a chance and I really resent
anybody saying that I'm just doing this
for the rich give me a break
I think you guys overplay that all the
time and it gets old and frankly Yatta
Yatta quit mister share of the public
leave suggest I'm not true okay I get
kind of sick and tired of it not true
it's a nice political play well mr.
Jeremiah all due respect I get sick and
tired of the richest regular order we do
attack and over and over again - how
many times do we do this
okay and then hatch went off on him some
more so you know again it is a really
tired talking point this idea that it's
the rich getting richer and the poor
getting poorer there's no evidence of
that the poor have gotten richer the
rich have gotten richer over the past
thirty years for sure and the idea that
that tax cuts solely benefit the people
at the top of the spectrum is just not
truth considering that the people at the
top of the spectrum are paying nearly
all of the net income tax in the United
States okay time for some things I hate
animal mail back it up okay so a couple
of quick things that I hate so Hillary
Clinton yesterday she was asked about an
investigation into her and why is she
still here like why she's still
bothering everyone she's she's someone
suggested that she sort of become the
rick astley of politics but you just got
rickrolled into into playing videos of
hillary clinton i think that's basically
correct also she apparently shops in in
the wardrobe fashioned by maria in by
julie andrews in sound of music like she
gets all of her clothes made from
curtains in any case here's a here's
hillary clinton talking about why an
investigation into her would be an abuse
of power if I try to take myself out of
it which you know is kind of hard
because it's personally offensive that
they would do this but taking myself out
of it
this is such an abuse of power and it
goes right at the rule of law okay so it
goes at the rule of law and she's
investigated but it doesn't go against
the rule of law when Jim Comey of the
FBI coordinates with the Obama
administration to let her off without
evidence
yeah that so I love this for Hillary
it's an abuse of power when she is
investigated but not an abuse of power
when she's led off for no reason that's
really exciting also I don't understand
why she's wearing like a necklace made
from balls from a ball crawl like
giggles and hugs that's confusing too
okay so enough making fun of Hillary's
wardrobe let's make fun of art so there
is a there's a Christie's
there's a Christie's Auction the other
day and there are a couple of pieces of
work that went for a lot of money so
there was a da Vinci painting of Jesus
that went for four hundred and fifty
million dollars which suggests that
somebody has too much money on their
hands and it doesn't look like Jesus it
looks kind of like the Mona Lisa with a
beard it's not it's not good but that
was not the bad painting the worst
painting was this okay so there
an artist I guess an inside Twombley now
I will acknowledge I don't know much
about modern art mainly because I think
most modern art is supreme garbage but
side Twombly is is a modern artist who
executed a series called the Bacchus
series who really deep really meaningful
ok this painting apparently sold
yesterday or a couple days ago for 40
million dollars for 4-0 million dollars
okay do you see this painting do you see
this my one and a half year old made
this for my fridge yesterday okay that's
what this looks like it's a bunch of
swirlies with paint but to care the
genius of it my yeah okay if this is
worth 40 million dollars then I can crap
something out worth 10 okay that's
that's insane so yeah I just want to
read you from Christie's because
Christie's was marketing it this way
collectively marking the culmination of
12 at least 50 years of painterly
practice the series comprises three
distinct sets the first of these six
eight feet high portrait forming
paintings was completed in 2004 towering
over the viewer at more than 10 feet
high and 16 feet wide how'd you like to
walk into your house and this is the
entire wall if this happened I would
immediately spank my son if they'd
actually I wouldn't he's great but I
would repaint the wall I mean for God's
sake like if this is this is your entire
wall it looks like Charles Manson's been
inside your house ridiculous says on
November 15th the masterwork will lead
the post-war and contemporary art
evening sale at Christie's in New York
it was executed using a pole too which
was affixed to brush drenched in richer
4,000,000 paints it's bright red spiral
seems to both climb and fall Twombly
allowed each of his marks to run down
the canvas suggesting the dripping of
wine or blood or like paint right says
the paintings basic looping motif was a
recurring theme in trombley's art this
form fascinated him for several years in
the meandering scroll of the blackboard
paintings of the late 1960s he explored
its capacity to convey through
repetition a sense of single continuous
field of energy here Twombly revisited
and developed this line in an epic scale
this is such bull okay this is it like
I'm sorry this is garbage
and
the idea that everything is art okay you
want to call this art call it art okay
but it's finger painting
it's bad art okay then that's it not to
get into deep philosophy here about art
but one of the things that makes art art
is a certain amount of skill to be an
artist means that you have perfected
your craft right there's a difference
between somebody like me who's very good
at violin and somebody who's
legitimately virtuosic on violin and the
difference is that person has more craft
than I do I've talked about art and
craft before I've talked about the idea
that craft will requires skill and what
I hate about modern art is that it's
much more about energy and it's all
subjective right I think that you can
say I think that you can objectively say
this is bad art I think there are
certain objective standards and I think
one of the standards you can apply is
how many people on earth could make this
everyone every person can make this okay
there's no one there elephants that can
make this at the zoo they legitimately
have zoos where two elephants like make
are then they sell them for like 15
bucks and it supports the the survival
of the elephants that seems to be a much
better spend than side Twombly's art the
the the leftist can the leftist idea
that subjectivity creates its own value
is so stupid then I can't even believe
it now listen if somebody does this mean
that the person who bought it has too
much money not necessarily it means that
the person who bought it has terrible
taste but the but the idea that art has
no standards whatsoever is the death of
everything right it's true in music we
look at people who play three chords and
suddenly they're Beethoven we look at
people who rhyme badly and suddenly
they're there Shakespeare the whole
purpose of art is that you are supposed
to be better at something than anyone
else and no other arena of American life
or Western life do we treat people like
this only in the artistic field do we do
this right you never do this with a
plumber you never would be like the
plumber wouldn't come in and screw up
your pipes you'd be like you know what
he really used his creativity there you
know I can take a hammer and beat on
that pipe and it gives me a new sense of
meaning like art is a job yeah art
requires skill this is why all of the
great artists spent years an
apprenticeship they spent years
perfecting their craft if you got if I
see something where I got up in the
morning and all I would have to do is
basically spit on his canvas and this
would now be art it makes me angry and I
think it's stupid okay and the person
who bought it is
how rich they are okay time for the
mailbag so Benjamin writes dear Ben what
books do you recommend for a novice in
the study of economic ideologies then
easily explain the errors of socialism
and communism thank you well Hayek has a
couple of books the that are that are
quite book that are quite good on this
the name of the Hayek book that is most
famous road to serfdom that's the one
that it sort of explains the the
failures of socialist economics
economics in one lesson is always the
easiest economics book and it explains
why Keynesianism is wrong there there
are a number of very good books Thomas
sells books on basic economics explain
it as well pal says do you practice the
infamous Shapiro smirk in the mirror
before your debates if I were to give it
a name like blue steel what would you
call it well I mean I don't actually
have a name for it I don't practice it
it's been natural since childhood I
assume there are certain kind of facial
tics that everyone has and that's just
one of mine the other one that I have is
what I'm thinking I tend to kind of roll
my eyes a little bit and I've been
working on that one because it annoys me
and my wife but I don't have a name for
it we'll have to we'll have to come up
with one so if you have any suggestions
Kyle we are perfectly willing to take
those under advisement Lamberto says hi
Ben recently I posted on Facebook and
exercise describing the horrible
situation in Venezuela due to their
socialist policies in response to that
article liberal friend of mine commented
saying Venezuela is a bad example of
socialism and Germany is a good example
of socialism why can't the u.s. be as
effective as Germany I didn't know
exactly how to counter that statement
perhaps you can help me out well
actually Venezuela is a better example
of socialism since it has more
government running of resources so
socialism and communism are based on
state ownership of resources if you want
to talk about heavy regulation and
redistribution of resources that really
is less socialism than it is what they
call sort of modified capitalism Germany
is much more along those lines than it
is like Germany is closer in economics
to the United States than it is to
Venezuela and the idea that because
Germany has extensive social programs
that it is that it is a socialist
country is just not true in the same way
that people say Denmark is a socialist
country except that it has some of the
lowest corporate tax rates on planet
earth and some of the and some of the
Laxus business regulations say very high
personal income tax rates and they have
a social safety net that's very
extensive they've had to cut all of that
back because they're bankrupting
themselves so even Germany isn't a good
example of how you can have a lasting
success like Germany has had some
economic success in the European context
compared their economy of the United
States it's not even close
Cedric says hey Ben do you think there
is any political and moral issue on
which the left is closer to the truth
than the right well it depends on which
elements of the right you are talking
about so I would say this there are
certain elements of the right that sort
of our libertarian in orientation not
with regards to government which i think
is right but with regards to human
nature this idea that we are all
atomistic individuals and that any
social standards are dangerous and there
is no communal social fabric you know
the left acknowledges that there's a
social fabric they just think that the
government has to force what the social
fabric is so if I have to choose between
the idea that there is a social fabric
and there is no social fabric or the
social fabric doesn't matter then I
think the social fabric matters I don't
think so you know in terms of in terms
of sort of the role of social fabric it
goes like this libertarians are here and
then there's left and then there's the
right over here so the left is actually
closer to the right in terms of
communitarian ideology with regard to
social fabric then hardcore
libertarianism but as far as generalized
leftist ideology
I don't think so very much alex says
what's your favorite food to eat during
Thanksgiving so stuffing is my thing
I will I will put away you like entire
pans and stuffing they are stuffing that
my mom makes an incredible Turkey in
fact no I phonetic along the way for
Thanksgiving but we are doing
Thanksgiving dinner in evening early
because we need to have my mom's cooking
my mom is an excellent cook mark says
God Emperor Shapiro that's that's
flattering I guess that clayman's been
to post I run a free speech group on my
campus what is the best what would you
say is the best way to deal with the
radical leftist who try to silence us
and heckle our events expose them get
out of camera and show them being idiots
and then get it to Daily wire and we
will put that up and we will mock them
because that is one of our joys in life
Emilio says hey is beer kosher and if so
what's your beer of choice so I'm not I
can't say I'm like a beer connoisseur
plain beer is always kosher because it's
made from grain it's not made from
grapes flavored beer is not always
kosher usually when I'm out I'll order
something with a Heineken or something
Kyle says according to modern science
humans been around for about a hundred
thousand years but the Bible states
we've been here for about seven thousand
years what's your opinion on that on an
evolution in general so I am NOT a a
fundamentalist with regard to timelines
in the Bible particularly in the
creation period so there's a book that I
a lot by a guy named Gerald Schroeder
I've recommended it on the show before
talking about how science melds with the
Bible I mean some obvious criticisms of
the of the literalist interpretation of
biblical dating pretty clearly for
example the the Bible says at the very
beginning there was there was night and
there was day the first day that happens
before the earth has been created before
the Sun has been created so what is the
timeline there's that really a 24-hour
period or is it something very different
so I don't think that the the Bible was
meant to be taken supremely literally
along those lines but if you're
conveying I'm not sure how you would
convey that the earth is hundreds of
thousands of years old and evolution
existed in a document that was that was
created 3,000 years ago for people who
had no idea what evolution is I had no
idea what species were had no idea about
periods of time I mean how to explain
carbon dating so you know I think that
God has a bit of a rough road to hoe in
terms of communication with human beings
he's always bound by the capacity of
human beings to understand which is
pretty clear even from the biblical text
when Moses said to God let me see her
face and God says I can't let you see my
face Gerald I I think that's pretty much
correct in perfect communication between
God and man is not a real possibility in
the sense that everything is always
going to be filtered through the prism
of the mind and God knows that Josh says
if the founders were alive today to see
what America has become what do you
think they might wish they could go back
and change or do differently well I
think that the the problem well I mean
listen I think if the founders were
alive today and you know many of them
were not raised in a context in which
slavery was appropriate they would
abolish slavery right off the bat I
think that they would also be a little
bit less sanguine about the power of the
judiciary I think that they would also
tremendously oppose the power of the
bureaucracy and they would put
restrictions in the Constitution against
it but the Constitution is a pretty good
document I'm not sure what exactly they
would change in order prohibit what
happened because all of the all of the
problems of the Constitution in terms of
government growth have been specifically
variations from the Constitution so
that's not because the founders embedded
anything in there that's wrong they
might have taken some of the
anti-federalists critiques a little bit
more seriously about the possibility of
growth and federal power but it's also
important to recognize that at the time
they were fighting against the Articles
of Confederation which were the weakest
form of government known to man
essentially Ryan says you've spoken
about voting for representation versus
voting for morality which rather have a
social
Saints in office or questionable
conservatives so the idea here is that
you are you know should you vote for
somebody who is moral but disagrees with
you or should you vote for somebody who
is questionable but agrees with you
so I again I'm going to reject the false
binary that we live in a system where we
can select immoral men who agree with us
but if but if the false binary is what
I'd rather have people who are who are
personally Saints but vote for socialism
versus what I rather have people who are
child molesters but are but but agree
with me if that is the false binary we
are creating of course you would have to
say that you would vote for the person
who most represents your priorities I
get that but I don't think that that's
the binary and I don't think that that
is a recipe for for a repeat election
cycle so here's one of the things that
that I said about the 2016 election I'll
say it again about Alabama elections do
not exist in a vacuum they're not one
time event the idea that how you vote in
this election impacts how the country
moves in future elections is a fact the
moral character of a country is built
off of repeated trials and errors okay
you don't get to take one election and
take it and crystallize it and say this
is the only election that has ever
mattered in the history of the world
when you do that you ends up in a world
of false binaries and that's how you end
up with a bunch of bad choices I think
that how you vote in elections how you
decide this makes a difference so if you
were to ask me is it worth sacrificing
one election so we can have a better
country
where there's the possibility that
everyone requires good people to be in
office and so next time my choice isn't
between a questionable conservative and
a socialist ain't is between a socialist
and a conservative st. then that's
something that I would that I think it's
worth sacrificing for I think that I
think that if we if we all hold by that
standard then we'll have more saints in
office and fewer sinners and more sane
to agree with us in office and fewer
sinners who agree with us in office so
you know the whole premise of my logic
on this politically is that sometimes
you have to take a short-term loss in
order to make a long term gain but I
think that we live in an era where if
you think that we can't take a short
term loss it's the end of the world if
we lose something or at the end it's the
or that even the possibility of losing
means that we have to vote a certain way
everything is crisis point a lot of
exigent circumstances require you to
make bad decisions and I think that
that's where we are repeatedly in
politics and I don't
that's where we ought to be Ryan says
sorry I just read his Lynn says Ben if
you were given the tasks were in a high
school without the Department of
Education getting in your way
what would you be teaching the students
in Y so I would be inculcating virtue so
I would spend some time actually talking
about the virtues and why they are
important in pursuing human happiness
this is something that we don't teach in
high schools anymore I would also be
pushing apprenticeships as opposed to
particular classes in in certain study
areas I think the learning skill sets is
actually a lot more important sometimes
than learning knowledge that you may
never use so but virtue is is my is my
key component I'll be teaching people
that happiness is reliant on you being a
virtuous human being and here are the
ways that you can make your life more
enlightened and more virtuous Austen
says by the way the founders agree the
founders agreed with me George
Washington talked routinely about this
being the role of education in a free
society a society that does not
inculcate virtue in the young is likely
to crumble when they're old Austin says
hi Ben is refusing funding to sanctuary
cities against the law if not how a
judge is able to block these executive
actions so no it's not against the law
the the basic rule I believe is that the
federal funding must be tied to
something that has to do with it being a
sanctuary City so this was ruled during
I believe the Reagan era because Reagan
tried to remove federal funding from
certain states that were that were not
cracking down on drunk driving in the
way that he wanted and so what they said
is that the funding that he's removing
has to be somehow logically connected to
the cause that he's attempting to push
you can't just randomly remove all
funding for a cause that is unrelated
Michael says what is the greater
overarching cause and problem that the
sexual assault charges stem from thanks
and love the show on true allegiance
especially your signature ones and will
belong to my son well I appreciate it
Michael he's so the greater overarching
cause that the sexual assault charges
stem from is again failures teach virtue
teaching boys not to rape is easy but if
it has no context if you're not supposed
to tea if you're not teaching boys an
affirmative virtue then they're likely
to fall into temptation more often the
same thing is true for young women who
are being told that is it listen sexual
assault is not the fault of women it's
the fault of the people who do the
sexual assaulting but you're increasing
risk when you tell people that a
libertine sexual order in which consent
is the only value is likely to lead to
happiness that leads to risk you're in
counters okay again the evil is the
fault of the evildoer the riskier
encounters are likely to increase the
prep or the proportion of encounters in
which an evil event happens Roderick
says Ben would you please explain that
neutrality I've done that before so I'm
gonna skip that one you can look back at
previous podcasts because I have talked
about that at length Christian says hey
Ben
I'm a big show up fan of the show from
Switzerland I was wondering is there any
way in which the US could learn from the
Swiss health care system I know it cost
us a lot of money but it seems to be
working very well with the individual
mandate why hasn't the us considered
such reform so Christian as you may have
seen in my debate when I say if you're
gonna have a government-run system it
should look like the Swiss health care
system I think that's right but I don't
think that a government-run health care
system is the best health care system so
Switzerland provides universality and
quality but not affordability it cost a
fortune
it's very very expensive in Switzerland
but is the United States willing to
absorb those costs I'm not sure the
United States is willing to absorb those
costs also you need to worry about the
creation of new products and services as
opposed to the redistribution of
existing ones and in a capitalist market
is the best way to do that
okay so final question here Braden's has
been I'm 22 years old married making a
good living my wife wants a baby as do I
however I'm afraid to be at a because I
didn't have one growing up and don't
have all great reference points to go
out for my youth what if any is your
advice on this
well Braden I think that the fact that
you acknowledge this is a problem is one
of the reasons why it sounds to me like
you're gonna be in good shape to
advocate recognizing your own flaws as a
person recognizing your own shortcomings
in your childhood things you want to do
better is a great way to raise kids
because it means they're gonna be
thinking yeah I've said this about I say
this to people all the time if you're
truly worried about sin if you're truly
concerned about your own level of
sinfulness you are less likely to sin
than if you're blind about your sin and
if you're truly worried about making
mistakes that means you're gonna think
twice before you make those mistakes so
what I would say is that you sound I
think you and your wife sounds like
would make very good parents and you
know if you're looking for great
reference points then try to find people
who you think are great parents get
close to them and try to learn from them
and try to put yourself in situations
where you can learn from other men you
admire so the day my dad always said
this when I was growing up that he liked
to have friends where I could look up to
them also and admire them when people
who treated me well as well I think that
you can do that too and I think that be
a worthwhile thing okay so we will be
back here on Monday hopefully the world
home on Tim
in our absence it's gonna be
Thanksgiving week next week so let's try
to have a happy week that'd be nice
have a great weekend I mention Pierrot
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]